A rich civilization that was once spread over Italy has founded old cities and perhaps has us
words left as "person" and "Rome" and even the alphabet.
The Romans?
No, no, not them.
I mean a former people whose language was almost lost to us.
Almost ... but not entirely.
Let me take you to Egypt in the mid-nineteenth century.
A European traveler is touring the city, and now he is shopping for a souvenir.
Roaming the streets he finds the perfect bargain: a sarcophagus with the mummy
still packed inside.
He drags it back to Vienna and sets it up as a scary showpiece in his house.
After his death it is donated to a museum where something strange is found.
The bandages of the mummy are filled with letters.
And not a few letters.
A whole book.
An enigmatic book.
It was not an Egyptian at all.
The ink reads inscriptions from Italy made by an ancient civilization such as the Romans
called Etrusci or Tusci.
Today we still call their native Tuscany (Truscani).
And now this mummy was wrapped here in the longest Etruscan text ever seen.
It was expensive, but this linen book had a problem.
A problem that it shared with thousands of others Etruscan inscriptions: the language seemed
in no other language.
Mysterious ... but deciphered.
These letters go from right to left, but turn them around and you will see them in fact
our letters are.
Look, the famous story goes that the ABCs are scattered from the Phoenicians, to Greece, to
Italy, where Rome inherited them.
However, we miss a part: it was the Etruscans who distributed the alphabet in Italy.
It seems that Greek alphabet that they have inherited had too many sounds for them.
Etruscans did fine with voiceless p, t, k, but they did not need the voting b, d, g.
In an inscription they even wrote the word "Greece" as "Creice".
This is why the Romans, when they borrowed the alphabet, originally made the C statements as well as both
k as g.
Looking at the Greek alphabet, it should only make the sound "g".
In my video about Latin letters this is why we have met an annoyed Roman who has added a tail
to that C to make our letter G.
But Etruscan did use sounds that are harder to distinguish.
Prepare your ears: p, t, k versus ph, th, kh.
Such as phersu, mask, a word that lives on in the heart of the English vocabulary.
Old reports tell us that they also missed the vowel "o".
Or, from a linguistic point of view, we would say that they do not distinguish between you and you.
If we believe the claim that the name Rome comes from the Etruscans, is an interesting example
the word Ruma.
So letters were missing in this book, but letters were also added.
Like this remarkable eight-looking symbol, previously written as / v / plus / h /.
The Romans cut away the H and left us the F. So this is a / f /.
Etruscans also had many letters for s sounds, but only used two at a time, one that suggests
that they were distinguished from sh.
But what do these letters mean?
The answers are in an old dictionary written by the last person who spoke Etruscan, Emperor Claudius!
Whose work has been lost.
No dictionaries.
No grammars.
And many discoveries, frustratingly enough, have never led to an Etruscan Rosetta stone
The experts turned to "guesswork": words pull out of the text and guess.
Is this by chance Indo-European?
No, clearly Semitic!
Wait, it's just like Basque!
No, no, Hungarian!
with the belly full of this vicious circle, Etruscologists have taken a new path.
Do not extract words from artifacts; let them in.
Then try out combinations like a code without a key.
Look at every inscription in its context.
Combine different meanings in different contexts until you
finds meanings that unlock every text.
It was brutal power, but this "Combinatory technique" slowly produced results.
We have a glimpse of a real language with real Grammar.
It had singular and plural nouns: "clan", "clenar", "ais", "aiser".
There were case ends, such as nominative -e at Creice.
pronouns such as mi, mini.
And verb forms: "tur" had a past tense "turuce".
We have uncovered a language that sounds dynamic and changeable.
Vowels became easier with time.
The hero Ajax was once Aivas but later became Eivas or Evas.
The word for the gods, the highest Etruscan concern, was plaintiff and later plaintiff.
They used core consonants where we would expect vowels: lautn.
Or maybe weak vowels, such as Atlnta.
These shattered Etruscan words suggest that language was undergoing a major shift.
After centuries of writing, inscriptions started to leave out vowels after the first consonant
The Etruscan name for itself was once Rasenna but Rasna became, and in one inscription
a Latin word is divided into preśnts.
It is an important indication that Etruscan words started with a heavy accent on their first syllable:
not / ra'senna / but / 'rasenna /.
Comparing translations and pronunciations yielded even more results.
Take quasi-bilingual, these inscribed Etruscan artifacts with a Latin or Greek Doppelgänger.
My favorite are 'talking objects', aristocratic gifts that speak for themselves: mini muluvanice
Laris Velχanas.
It is very quirky, but it is plausible when we find out that objects talk that way
in Latin and Greek and Venetian.
We even found hints of a context for the language itself, a language that is so different
from his neighbors.
A fascinating stone from the Greek island of Lemnos is surrounded by a soldier
by letters and words that really resemble Etruscan.
Is this a lost sister language?
A dialect?
Perhaps Etruscan was not so alone.
Did it belong to a larger family of Tyrrhenian languages?
The language of that linen book is still mysterious.
We do not know how this text ended up in Egypt, but thanks to all this work we can say it
is a kind of ritual calendar.
And sometimes we can follow whole lines of text: "celi huθiś zaθrumiś flerχva
neθunsl śucri θezric ".
It's almost like if you close your eyes I can take you back to the days of fluent Etruscan,
but ask how you can say a simple yes or no and we are lost again.
Hang around and subscribe for language.